[Applause]
yes get out of here get out of
here I got got you no I didn't touch the
wall I think I got you I didn't touch it
I want to see that again I didn't touch
the wall I want to see that never so the
guy so the man who said he would not
lose 24 no a no way no excuses Mr you or
not we don't want to hear would I did
not run through the tape yeah you
did lost you know hey Ernest new glasses
oh my God glasses now and I thought it's
the glasses now and I thought I tuck was
here and I missed the wall I actually
missed it chu chu a winner Chuck's a
winner conations call me Chuck call me
champ okay nice race there no that was
not
a anyway do it again
Kitty anyway the one thing that
chuckster's got an answer for you that's
right
hey broken broken we going to have a new
movie broken
broken hey how about that Phoenix big
three k one more time
keny the big three let it go so the big
three as they bring B down you know you
know you see before you hear them but it
free it here right there to me they
never break the plane truck we talk
about point guard they're a great jump
shooting team boom shot goes in they
score with prolific ability from the
outside even Kevin Durant who gets into
the he starts breaking the plane but he
he's much more comfortable taking the
pullup jump shot Again Bradley Bill gets
it in the break we in freeze it h we're
in transition I'm going to get in
transition and get downhill but instead
of getting downhill what happens he
pulls back shoots the three now the
difference between when he was at Golden
State Steph Curry himself they used to
break the plane
so that was that was excellent analysis
but the highlight of this half time
report will be the replay of uh of of
this of this race oh he bad glasses and
he's sick here they are look at the form
look
at oh yeah CH okay CH I didn't touch I
didn't touch I didn't even touch
it I got you
brother he aded it get the
wall oh okay Chuck where to reach out
for it Chuck the man who was not going
to lose in 2024 got St PR stop
practicing
is